[Música]
hola bienvenidos una vez más a canadá en
las américas café
el programa semanal de radio canadá
internacional este formato con el que
ustedes ya están familiarizados de radio
televisión de televisión web etcétera
etcétera que ustedes están
familiarizados
nosotros estamos encontrando caminos
aquí estamos una vez más en este
reencuentro semanal este reencuentro que
le proponemos cada siete días a ustedes
por los diversos canales de comunicación
nuestro sitio en internet www r6 net
punto sea
louis le decían el rey de la
articulación también tenemos nuestro
canal de youtube en donde ustedes nos
pueden seguir en vivo cómo están
ocurriendo en este momento con muchos de
ustedes seguramente y a través de
facebook live
y también les ofrece la ocasión de
seguirnos en vivo en nuestro sitio de
internet como ustedes saben dentro de
una hora más o menos un poquito menos
tal vez tendrán la emisión ya puesta en
línea y quienes elijan quienes tengan la
ocasión quienes tengan el premio de
seguirnos a través de su sitio de
internet podrán acceder en la buena
fortuna los temas musicales que por
razones técnicas y de derechos no
difundimos a veces hay que decirlo claro
el tema es que
gracias a la transmisión facebook
facebook tiene reglas geolocalizadas no
estrictas con respecto a la música
nosotros aquí en radio que nada se pagan
derechos por la música se pueden emitir
en la tele se puede emitir en la radio
mientras no salga de la frontera
canadiense entonces en ese caso
lamentablemente si nosotros lo ponemos
ya nos ha pasado ponerlo y que se ha
cancelado el live por eso ocurren esos
medios es muchas veces uno quiere
acceder a un contenido en algún medio
por ejemplo yo el otro día estaba
tratando de consultar contenido en un
medio de españa y el vídeo que yo quería
ver no corría diciendo decir que
realmente que no lo podía haber debido a
mi ubicación hay gente que no está al
tanto de eso entonces empieza a
insultarme lo que sí hay que decir
también es que es para proteger los
derechos de autor de los artistas de los
músicos canadienses y pues así es y eso
hay que protegerlo podemos haber estado
hablando desde hace unos instantes sin
presentarnos
malísima aunque esté ya nos conocen
tenemos allí a nuestro conocido amigo y
colega mucho pablo gómez barrios
un saludo puede ser extenso a su
izquierda paloma martínez qué tal le es
un gusto estar acá aquí a mi derecha
inmediatamente está alió nardo gimeno
que está agonizando buenos días buenas
noches y mi nombre es luis laborda hoy
somos los cuatro de este equipo que los
vamos a acompañar pero además ustedes
ven allí en en la otra punta de la mesa
a una invitada que es ángela sierra
alguna ustedes ya la conocen la hemos
entrevistado
creo que en más de una ocasión por
diversos temas latinarte inclusive o el
festival
pero hoy nos vas a hablar dentro de unos
instantes de otro tema que es la casa de
las américas del proyecto que alguna vez
hemos comentado también aquí y que ahora
se encuentra en pleno proceso de pre
producción
apertura en todo el trabajo de
organización que requiere un
emprendimiento de ese tipo y por
supuesto eso necesita recursos necesita
financiamiento nos vas a hablar de una
campaña de financiamiento que cuando lo
necesite
no es la única que necesita
como sea pero hay también existe
[Risas]
con solamente unos instantes pero hoy es
el 17 de mayo de 2019 se cumplen 377
años de la fundación de montreal
qué tal una señora ya adulta del 17 de
mayo de 1642 pobre yo me di fundó lo que
se llamó en ese momento la aldea de
vilmarie y hoy conocemos como la ciudad
de montreal usted tiene alguna donde
está y estamos es justamente lo que voy
a decir que estamos en el bar en el
barrio bil mayor en el barrio 1000 mah y
entonces donde es las primeras zonas de
las ciudades más antiguas cerca de las
zonas más antiguas de mantener una
ciudad cosmopolita una ciudad
multilingüe una ciudad con muchos
espacios verdes extensa con un río que
la recorre de oeste a 20 años han lo
harán con el viejo mundial como acaba de
decir pablo que es muy característico de
la ciudad con el puente siaka tiéné que
es uno de los iconos de esta ciudad que
ha salido mal elízaga de la cuadra del
estadio lineal coordenada de olímpico
efectivamente que no siempre ha sido muy
querido por todo el mundo ha sembrado
más de una discordia pero hay
mi parque parque porque es el parque
cerquita de casa de pablo es el que
parece ése es el jardín botánico pero al
lado está uno de los parques más grandes
de la ciudad de montreal que es el
parque mesón y que caracteriza a ese
parque en duración a otros que lo
diferencian todo caso que tiene ese
parque
[Risas]
es el parque ese es mi pista de
entrenamiento ahí donde voy a trotar en
las mañanas de un par de terrenos
también comprados
[Risas]
entonces la ciudad de montreal que
decían cumple 377 años ustedes
recordarán muchos de ustedes seguramente
los festejos que se hicieron hace un par
de años con pompas y platillos
festejaron los 375 años pompas platillos
y mucho dinero que se puso en esos
festejos
pero seguramente cada uno de ustedes
tendrá algún primer recuerdo porque todo
lo que estamos aquí hemos elegido
montreal para vivir no hemos nacido aquí
puede ser primer recuerdo que tienen
ustedes cada uno de ustedes es su primer
encuentro entre al montreal yo me bajé
del avión - acá mi hermano
y su familia no hace tanto frío
el 2 de marzo no hace tanto frío al día
siguiente me llevo mi hermano a hacer el
trámite de la carta de residencia y ahí
hacía frío ese fue el primer impacto fue
termostático porque decidí en marzo
porque en realidad se estaban justo
nosotros venimos haciendo los trámites
fue antes de la caída y los seis
presidentes de argentina y tal fatídico
2000 2001 nosotros vimos empezar los
trámites antes y nos dieron la visa para
esa época y empezó a cambiar
el cambio entonces no me alcanzaba para
comprar pasajes así que efectivamente
fue ese lo que dice comprar el pasaje
para verlo ambos pronto lo más pronto
posible para poder empezar porque yo mi
casa yo seguía unos años después sin
embargo lo que cuando tuve la vista que
fue hacia fines del 2003 le comunique a
una conocida que vivía aquí en no bueno
no es motivación en gatineau enfrente de
ottawa que ya tiene la vice que me iba a
venir y ella dijo no no no soy des antes
del mes de abril
[Risas]
se cumplieron 2 208 días 208 días de que
el mercurio no sobrepasaba los 20 grados
de temperatura a un viejo producto de
televisión los dedos con el que yo
trabajé muchos años que cuando empezaba
el invierno ponía un título en la
pantalla que decía faltan 365 días para
el verano
es más o menos lo mismo a tu primer
recuerdo mi recuerdo también es con
temperatura porque yo llegué el 23 de
agosto hacía un calor hacía muchísimo
calor en montreal el frío yo sí yo
decidí venir en verano porque en
realidad iba a comenzar la universidad
de un año de universidad en septiembre
entonces hay que llegar en esa última
semana de agosto y me la pasé muy bien
porque y lo que más me gustó es que
podía caminar por la calle sin miedo de
noche de día y después me compré una
bicicleta y ahí sí la libertad fue casi
absoluta te vamos a demostrar la cápsula
de nuestros bicicleteros
[Música]
porque radio-canadá a toda la
institución ha hecho una especie de
pequeño clip para promover el uso de la
bicicleta y a quienes en toda la
sociedad radio canadá que es inmensa y
que hay muchísimos empleados aquí en ese
línea muchísimos ciclistas y
motociclistas y quienes eligió a dos
viejos y probados y viejos a ellos así
que habría que mostrarlos
[Música]
en el recuerdo de tu primer reencuentro
y el mío no fue termostático como dice
nuestro buen amigo leonardo pero yo
llegué en pleno verano
el 5 de junio
en 1975 hace un rato no era el pleno
verano y lo que me llamó la atención
primero que todo fue la arquitectura de
montreal las escaleras hacia ahora las
escaleras afueras de húmero en caracas
en frente de las casas y me preguntó no
sabía por qué estaba llegando no estaba
recién desempacado bajado desde el avión
y no todavía no entendía
porque esas escaleras y finalmente pues
esa esa imagen se quedó grabada en mi
mente y yo la tengo siempre la conservo
y cada vez que me paseo por montreal
me encanta ver las escaleras que mucha
gente dice que es una de las imágenes
distintivas de montreal es esa lista de
esas escaleras en el frente de las casas
que se van a acceder a las viviendas que
están en esos edificios por lo general
es son construcciones que no superan las
2 o 3 plantas y en algunos casos se
trata de escaleras necesariamente detrás
en forma de caracol de los frentes a
veces son los derechas y en algunos
casos escaleras hechas en madera y la
estructura de hecha en madera talladas
muy decoradas que son características de
esta ciudad y nuestra invitada a la
sierra que es su primer encuentro con la
ciudad la primera vez que yo vine a
montreal línea
a visitar de paseo de turista y fue en
mayo del 99 y me recuerdo el mejor
recuerdo que nunca se me ha olvidado y
que ha hecho que ese lugar sea mi lugar
preferido de montreal fue mi visita al
centro de historia de montreal que es un
museo
en una casa de bomberos
en el viejo montreal y había una
exposición permanente y había un vagón
de tranvía un falso vagón de tranvía
cuando no se subía antes hoy a la música
y se movía y las imágenes de montreal
iban pasando por las ventanas nunca se
me olvidará y sigue siendo el centro de
montreal mi lugar preferido que es el
museo se pueden visitar excavaciones que
está en el mismo lugar
está detrás de punta caliente y de hecho
el centro historia mostrar va a cambiar
de lugar
así que vienes al catering
zhang jing is
y en la casa de bomberos se convierte en
un anexo a punta calidad entonces
está una de las primeras
casarme
[Música]
que no me tiene recuerdo de material yo
no llegué a montreal cuando viene a
vivir a canadá sino que llegue al
casting o enfrente de agua del lado del
quebec pero en frente de ottawa de la
capital nacional y mi primera vez aquí
en montreal fue cuando viene a visitar a
unos amigos que vivían en ese entonces
en el de ser una pequeña isla que está
en el medio del río san lorenzo enfrente
de lo que sería más o menos el centro de
montreal o el barrio de verdad mejor
dicho al que pertenece a su vez el deseo
y recuerdo que me resultaba bastante
laberíntica la ciudad sobre todo para
conducir y no era yo el que iba al
volante a mi lado para que empiecen las
críticas y cuando pensábamos que íbamos
hacia el sur para dirigirnos hacia
él dice que está siendo para él no
terminamos apareciendo en el límite del
norte de montreal como 25 kilómetros
también hay un río
porque el ala el diagrama de la ciudad
en el centro de montreal es bastante
típico entre comillas con respecto a las
paralelas a cal es una vacuna viene
avenidas y tal cuando uno sale a la
periferia del centro de montreal en
cierto eso cambia hay una calle que se
llama lake por ejemplo donde yo vivo que
viene de este oeste y en un momento dado
va de norte a sur y después vuelve
después la basura después vuelve para lo
que sea y uno en lake no es para nada
ley no es paralela esta es paralela a
aquella en este tramo en ese tramo es
paralela a la otra que cruza sea por eso
te entiendo es realmente algo particular
de monte como complemento simple no
solamente en el centro de la ciudad sino
de las autopistas y lo mismo una de las
características que recién hace un
tiempo y no termina de acostumbrarse es
que por lo general las señalizaciones en
las autopistas están muy cerca de la
salida o de entrada que no debe tomar
entonces cuando se enteran ya no tienen
y recuerdo que le preguntamos a una
persona no me acuerdo que parte de
montreal bajamos en autopista le
preguntamos una persona cómo hacemos
para ir a la dirección a la que
queríamos llegar yo intenté preguntarle
en el caso magro y rudimentario francés
más rudimentario francés como el que
tiene en esa época como hacíamos para
llegar con inglés al francés mejor
hablando en inglés y ahí me contestó
francés
si me quería confundir si me quería ser
practicada en argentina salimos el 24 o
el 31 una noche salimos a festejar y
vamos al centro de pasear y montón
cliente estuvimos la loca idea con mi
esposa de salir en el 31 de uno de
nuestros primeros treinta y buenos aquí
y no es lo mismo
quién va a salir bueno la historia es
que salimos por nosotros bien el oeste
de la isla agarramos la autopista hay
dos autopistas que pasan montreal la
cuarentena 20 agarramos la 40 hacia el
centro y que tenemos que doblar está en
la próxima fue para el puerto pero al
puerto lejos del puerto sino y me
encontré en un lugar privado del puerto
y salió un oficial así que si usted es
muy escaso madre todo lo que le dije
[Risas]
todas estas anécdotas para entonces
homenajeadas de alguna manera enfocar
una mente pero homenaje a la del fin a
esta ciudad en montreal que tanto 377
años si tenemos la gente que nos está
viendo y saludos en este caso van águila
en abril dice saludos desde acá papel y
siempre es un placer cuando puedo
seguirlos en directo top fun me encanta
esto quería top fun gustavo lucas desde
la ciudad de melo departamento de cerro
largo en uruguay louis valderas saludos
desde san antonio en chile siempre
creator ir los amigos de radical
internacional pablo nos está mirando el
rovira también me saludó dice miguel
rovira desde barcelona españa toda
amigos oyentes y componentes del
programa un fuerte abrazo y beso si
muchos 73 que era uno de los mensajes
que damos
rovira
yo quisiera agregar solamente para el 17
porque estábamos hablando del 17 de mayo
hoy hablamos de
377 de montreal pero un 17 de mayo más
reciente de 1990
la organización mundial de la salud
eliminó de su lista de enfermedades
mentales la homosexualidad entonces
desde desde esa fecha los 17 de mayo se
celebra el día internacional contra la
homofobia la transfobia y la bifobia en
todo el mundo y bueno pues quería
resaltar eso también
hoy en el día a veces exacto más tarde
pues estará en línea se entrevista pues
hecho el recordatorio también de esa
fecha y luego decíamos cuando empezamos
nuestra emisión de hoy tenemos una
invitada que es ángela sierra que en el
día de hoy viene a hablar del proyecto
de la casa de las américas recordamos
refrescarnos de qué se trata ese
proyecto alguna vez lo hemos comentado
pero pues el público no todo el público
conoce la idea de que se trata bueno la
casa de las américas es la casa de todos
pero sobre todo es una iniciativa de la
comunidad latinoamericana
a festejar nuestra identidad
latinoamericana los latinos estamos por
todas partes y en ninguna parte porque
no tenemos un punto de encuentro y desde
hace algunos años cuando nace la
fundación latina arte nació con el
objetivo de crear un centro cultural
latinoamericano sin embargo no estamos
posicionando un poco la marca al nombre
festival y
no sé cómo siete años después le dijimos
al consejo administración por favor
denos una luz si lo realizamos o no lo
realizamos y la respuesta al consejo
administración de la fundación latinarte
fue no no es un proyecto muy grande es
un proyecto muy ambicioso nos podemos
perder todo el esfuerzo que hemos hecho
durante todos estos años para posicionar
latinarte pero al mismo tiempo que se
negó dio un consejo y ese consejo era
que le entregaremos el proyecto a la
comunidad entonces se convirtió en un
proyecto que no es solamente cultural
sino que también es de negocios y
también es comunitario han pasado tres
años desde que trabajamos todos los días
en el proyecto
iniciamos una convocatoria que duró
siete meses
y luego de siete meses nos dimos cuenta
que bueno éramos 25-26 fijos decidimos
una una razón jurídica es que queremos
ser una empresa privada un organismo sin
ánimo de lucro o una cooperativa y
escogimos el modelo de cooperativa somos
una cooperativa de solidaridad estamos
constituidos desde el año pasado ya
pasamos nuestra primera asamblea general
vamos para la segunda tenemos un consejo
de administración de siete personas
liderado por pablo luna triana que tiene
24 años y que es a la imagen de la nueva
comunidad latinoamericana de montreal
un joven trilingüe super joven
estudiante de aquí ya trabajando aquí o
sea que ya es una nueva imagen de lo que
es la comunidad latinoamericana el
objetivo principal no es otro que crear
comunidad y hacer que los 135 mil 400
latinos de montreal se den cuenta de su
potencial económico social y lo mismo
este punto de cuatro va a servir de un
lugar de discusión con los otros
organismos
en el gobierno para que se den cuenta de
este valor tan grande este potencial que
tenemos los latinos en montreal
paralelamente lógicamente que vamos a
trabajar con la comunidad de acogida y
vamos a hacer un trabajo intercultural
muy importante porque seguido a los
estudios del profesor armónico con base
de los estudios del profesorado que
trabajamos pues conocemos la salud
económica de nuestra comunidad que no es
la mejor pero también conocemos los
problemas a los que nos tenemos que
enfrentar y lo que tenemos que tratar de
arreglar que son todos estos problemas
un poco de imagen de los latinos y un
problema de la el problema de la
pronunciación el francés y bueno a veces
se confunden a los latinos haberes
latina entonces baila salsa si también
hay muchos tipos yo trabajé hace un par
de años atrás en un nuevo mundo
televisión en televisión en un canal de
televisión que ya no está más al aire
de solo español aquí en montreal y el
problema siempre fue
poder amalgamar toda la comunidad latina
porque nosotros nos llamamos comunidad
latina pero hay un montón de
latinoamericanos por una cuestión
geográfica que no se sienten parte de un
proyecto de estas características porque
no se sienten latinos bien como se hace
también se sienten parte del estereotipo
cómo se hace para poder hacer no hay que
olvidar que es la casa de las américas
entonces lógicamente que es es un
trabajo que se hace sobre varias fases
no particularmente son tres fases la
primera fase es lograr que esta
comunidad se una lograr que esta
comunidad converja ese punto de
encuentro y de allí crear esa comunidad
nosotros antes de empezar hicimos una
encuesta hace tres años una encuesta
donde les decíamos a los latinos donde
se reúnen los latinos donde están los
latinos que quieren encontrar en esa
casa de las américas y donde la quieren
encontrar
las respuestas lo que hicieron fue
apoyar la la necesidad de este proyecto
y decirnos si sigan adelante en donde
están los latinos en todas partes y en
ninguna parte
donde quieren estar los latinos en
cualquier lugar al lado de un metro para
que podamos llegar y donde se reúnen los
latinos y nos dimos cuenta que los
latinos a reunir en los comercios
latinos en la tienda a veces nombraban
la iglesia por allá nombraron a
latinarte por allá en un rinconcito pues
en latín arte pero eso ha valido nuestra
la pertinencia del proyecto y desde hace
tres años que nos soltamos es decir ya
somos 30 latinoamericanos y que
invertimos cada uno dos mil dólares es
decir que tenemos 60 mil dólares de
arranque estamos buscando a reunir los
100 mil dólares porque con 100 mil
dólares vamos a poder jugar mejor a lado
por el lado de los préstamos de las
márgenes de crédito pero también estamos
en una economía solidaria y no hay que
olvidar que fuera de las grandes
instituciones financieras y los grandes
bancos
hay también una economía solidaria muy
fuerte muy fuerte el movimiento
cooperativo en quebec es uno de los más
fuertes y que cuenta con una de las
cooperativas más grandes de américa que
es el movimiento de jackson
así que
es una locura bien pensada es a veces la
gente dice pero como hacen están en
todos los frentes y cómo va a ser y
créanme que si la convocatoria duros
duró siete meses no fue porque somos
súper unidos y todos estábamos de
acuerdo duró siete meses o que nos tocó
convencer a 30 almas latinas de vamos
somos capaces y podemos porque nunca nos
identificamos como latinos expresiva yo
soy argentino soy colombiano mexicano
nosotros nos pasaba en el momento de voy
a buscar publicidad y vamos a buscar de
una nacionalidad y ya porque yo voy a
poner publicidad si el presentador es de
tal nacionalidad porque estamos hablando
no en la lengua porque la misma cultura
es la que compartimos ya hay elementos
que nos unen
pero hay esa esa cuestión de esa
reticencia este orgullo también nacional
me imagino de algunas de las personas
hay de todo hay ahí el latino que está
muy bien adaptado que trabaja muy bien
que no necesita su comunidad dice pero
yo de todas maneras nunca me junto con
los latinos no se te olvida que vaya
bien
y hay otros que sí unámonos y no pero
tampoco vamos a crear un centro
comunitario de todos juntos ya no es la
verdad es es algo que ha sido pensado
más a esta nueva manera de ver la
latinidad en montreal que es a la imagen
de estos 25 35 años que de pronto no son
tan latinos porque ya son más de aquí o
porque de pronto ya nacieron aquí
crecieron acá pero que tienen ese gusto
y ese amor por américa latina pero hay
otro público súper importante que no
podemos olvidar y es el montreal es el
los amantes del mundo en que quieren
aprender español que quieren estar al
tanto de américa latina que viajan
seguido américa latina y que tienen
amigos latina ahora cuando nos
comunicamos me dijiste que están en
plena campaña de financiamiento para
conseguir esos fondos que necesitan para
poder lanzar en pleno el proyecto
entonces las personas interesadas en
compartir esta iniciativa y en aportar
esta iniciativa cómo se pueden poner en
contacto con ustedes bueno en la campaña
de socio financiación se está haciendo a
través de una plataforma que se llama
foundries que es una plataforma
canadiense
estamos en el día 16 empezamos al
primero de mayo vamos hasta el 7 de
junio en todo lo que tiene que hacer es
hashtag casa de las américas o hashtag
mes donde sabe reik y allí sale toda la
información somos 30 porque no tenemos
plataformas no tenemos sitio web estamos
trabajando con la plataforma las redes
sociales y los sitios web de cada
miembro de la cooperativa estamos
dividiendo la el esfuerzo por 30 y si
ustedes hacen el hashtag les va a salir
el perfil de todos los miembros
hicimos un vídeo que está está rodando
por todas las las redes y por todos los
lugares de interés de la web y ese vídeo
muestra a los 30 representantes de la
casa de las américas con sus empresas
con su interés con sus sueños de porque
están aliados al proyecto y me decía
cuando caminábamos hacia el estudio que
la idea es que en definitiva en la casa
de las américas pueda abrir sus puertas
ya oficialmente hacia el mes de octubre
el primero de octubre estamos haciendo
todo lo posible para que ese sueño se
haga realidad y el primero de octubre
invitar a todos los latinoamericanos ya
los latina migos a que vengan a abrir la
casa de las américas
porque porque no es otro esfuerzo que el
de superhéroes la iniciativa que
seguramente sube mucho esfuerzo mucho
tiempo recursos ideas sin resolución de
conflictos claro lógicamente porque no
todos pensamos igual no todos tenemos
los mismos intereses
en el objetivo entonces el mismo es
decirles tener este punto de encuentro y
yo les quiero decir la cosa la casa de
las américas de montreal será la primera
casa de las américas de américa del
norte así que
es un logro mayor que esperamos verla
buscando no lo encuentro
abriendo el videito
yo quería agregar que antes de venir
aquí a canadá yo salí de barranquilla en
1972 y me fui hacia el sur me fui hacia
argentina y estuve viviendo en buenos
aires
el primer lugar donde yo llegué a buenos
aires porque había llegado sin un
centavo tenía hambre no tenía dónde
vivir al final era exactos y hippie
entonces me encontré con un dominicano y
que me dice bueno que empecé me empiezo
a hablar con él y me sé dónde está
viviendo y algunos que estoy en la calle
no no tengo donde vivir por el momento y
se ven te voy a llevar a un lugar
te va a agradar y me llevo a este lugar
que se llamaba la casa latinoamérica o
la casa latinoamericana en aquella época
la casa latinoamericana en monte en
buenos aires y tu proyecto me hace
pensar un poco pues en viejo recuerdo no
de la casa latinoamericana en buenos
aires donde se reunía a la gente de
distintos lugares de américa aquellos
dominicanos en buenos aires porque llegó
hasta allá
la única clase que yo quiero hacer es
que no es el proyecto de la sierra no es
el proyecto de la tina arte si nació en
latín arte pero es el proyecto de toda
la comunidad de toda la comunidad porque
nosotros
en estos tres años nos hemos encontrado
con tanta gente con tantos
latinoamericanos en las convocatorias y
las reuniones que se hacían cada 15 días
cada 15 días estábamos conociendo
latinos nuevos y amantes del mundo
latino nuevos entonces se volvió un
proyecto colectivo mayor no teníamos
mucha suerte ese proyecto vamos a seguir
al tanto de su derrotero
tú te quedas aquí no te vas hasta el
final de la misión pero si vengo aquí
digo garcía y saludos ángela sierra hoy
desde colombia y mañana con ustedes en
este género proyecto felicitaciones
enormes nancy remedir mirad dice saludos
desde en el sí perdón de saludos de ese
santa ana do livramento brasil y diego
my friend hice genial la casa de las
américas felicitación try friends esos
son los mensajes que queríamos compartir
bueno otra de las propuestas que hicimos
desde este espacio a nuestro público es
que envíen vídeos
para que demuestren el lugar en el que
viven la forma de vida las
características etcétera que debemos
conocer los sitios en los que pide el
público tan variado que nos sigue semana
a semana y una de las personas que nos
hizo llegar un vídeo es miriam alarcón
que es de tucumán
entonces es un vídeo es un vídeo de
tucumán y paloma tiene alguna
descripción que nos hizo ser la autora
de este vídeo al respecto si dice yo
vivo en villa carmela tucumã en
argentina en la provincia más pequeña
del país en el noroeste en el vídeo y él
puso acento vídeo en sede la escuela del
barrio se ven carteles de campaña
política estamos en época electoral
aparece la pequeña plaza bien pintada y
con el pasto cortado por la misma razón
la ruta 315 es por donde pasan los
vehículos al costado de la ruta se ven
limoneros la provincia es líder en
producción y exportación de limones en
esta zona de tucumán se caracteriza por
su exuberante vegetación como está
nublado no se ven los cerros el paisaje
es bonito yo elegí este pero desde otro
punto se ven hermosos los cerros
eso es todo saludos a todos y me gusta
mucho lo que hacen gracias por el
trabajo con tanta dedicación hasta el
día
es conocida como el jardín
mil gracias a miriam alarcón queremos
más
y necesitamos al resto de que nos siguen
a mí y me está fuertemente nos salen
tantos
vídeos con sus lugares de residencia
muéstrenos de qué se trata queremos
conocerlo queremos saber no todos
conocemos toda américa latina así como
[Risas]
otro que se animó a hacer su vídeo es el
señor pablo claro y los invitamos a
tratar la idea es que yo les decía que
hay que mostrar por el ejemplo y bueno
los que nos están escuchando no conocen
montreal o muy pocos lo conocen entonces
pero la idea es mostrarles un poco y
este vídeo que vamos a ver
de una iglesia entre otros que está muy
cerca de aquí de radio canadá entonces
pero la idea también es mostrarles qué
ha habido una desafección de los
quebequenses por la iglesia y podemos
ver que esta es una de las iglesias que
ha sido abandonada de alguna forma por
sus feligreses
ahí me llama siempre la atención no el
estado no va a saber creo nunca una
iglesia así en latinoamérica no sea
porque todavía es ese fervor y todavía
es el catolicismo es bastante fuerte
mientras que aquí se deslindó un poco a
partir de los años 60 con la revolución
tranquila y bueno pues siempre me llamó
la atención cuando pasó por delante de
esta iglesia que está desierta y no hay
nadie entra está cerrado está cercana a
otro que no lo particular es eso y que
siempre me pregunte por qué en el mismo
barrio casi en la misma calle con dos
cuadras de distancia hay dos iglesias
la ciudad de las iglesias no nos separa
en el monte real en el mont wáyar y mira
y se ven un montón de techo verde varios
hay hay un número de campanarios es como
la ciudad de los nosecuántos campanarios
hay que buscar muchísimos un vídeo
entonces que muestra el estado de esta
iglesia que está cercana aquí a radio
canadá cercana de las 12 desde esta es
la que estamos
y vamos a inaugurar en dos meses más a
principios del año próximo
ese es otro ejemplo de los vídeos que
pueden hacer ustedes y haciendo llegar y
los pasaremos los difundiremos aquí en
nuestra en nuestro programa
poco tiempo minutos para ver más preciso
conocimientos para que nosotros los
cuatro que estamos aquí presente cada
uno el tema o uno de los temas que ha
estado trabajando a lo largo de esta
semana invitó entonces a paloma primero
a presentar este trabajo así lo voy a
terminando mi teléfono por aquí tengo la
información es un reportaje que hice
un especialista del diseño inclusivo es
el diseño para gente que tiene alguna
algún problema
nos algún tipo de minusvalía y entonces
están trabajando en un proyecto se llama
el foro access
change hicieron ahí un reto en el que
los jóvenes diseñadores hacían
aparatitos para poder adaptar los juegos
de vídeo a personas con discapacidades
entonces me encantó conversar con ann
louise and louise davidson que trabaja
en la universidad concordia que habla
muy bien español por cierto porque fue
américa latina' hacer proyectos con
jóvenes jóvenes allá entonces
conversamos con ella y de hecho tengo un
vídeo ahí pero ya no hay tiempo para
verlo hoy como cordero toma muestra pero
muestra justamente los diferentes
aparatos que estuvieron construyendo en
este proyecto de inclusión de diseño
inclusivo voy a tratar de un escritor
argentino canadiense con una enorme
colección con una enorme colección de 40
mil libros
que él tenía en francia bueno es un
argentino canadiense que vivió acá
veinte años en canadá y bueno es un
trotamundos no ha vivido en muchos
lugares del mundo y no sé si su
biblioteca es la de la copa pero tenía
en francia donde estaba últimamente
tenía esta biblioteca y escribió un
libro él fue invitado en el marco del
festival literario metrópolis blue e iba
a presentar
mientras en valor mi biblioteca que él
se uno de sus últimos libros y habla de
esta biblioteca pero que finalmente es
un pretexto para hablar de literatura y
para hablar del amor por los libros
recordemos que manguel fue el lector de
jorge luis borges cuando vos sabés
porque cuando era joven porque él
trabajaba digo manguel trabajaba en una
librería y borges frecuentaba esa
librería en un momento dado le dijo ya
estaba ciego le dijo me puedes hacerle
el cni
y fue así en fin es un reportaje que
habla un poco del amor de los libros que
tiene este hombre y con el que todos
tenemos nuevo el amor a los libros y que
es interesante pues ver esa perspectiva
y que en alguna mudanza llevándome
libros precisamente por dar fe de lo
costoso que es hoy día trasladar libros
yo lo único mientras que fueron mis
libros y mi música y mis libros fue el
único argentino yo no hago tú tu crónica
digital rápidamente en realidad es casi
casi una noticia en una crónica y es que
el primer ministro canadiense prometió
una carta digital para luchar contra el
fenómeno de el odio en internet esto
sale de su reunión con líderes de varios
países en parís
ayer y antes de ayer y ayer y bueno en
este caso el primer ministro canadiense
dijo que va a hacer esta carta
canadiense en contra del odio y que
vendrá con obligaciones y sanciones para
las empresas e instituciones que no la
respeten y es éstos nacen todos después
de los atentados en christchurch
y se hizo el llamamiento el llamamiento
christchurch que bueno fue en realidad
una reunión de líderes montón de países
y de asociaciones para evitar el odio en
internet y bueno acá nada está como
precursora y con esta carta digital que
va a presentar el primer ministro y tú
louis perfecto yo por mi parte les
ofrezco dentro de la enorme cantidad
material de producción y producción un
reportaje que publica el día lunes sobre
algo que me llamó mucho la atención y es
el hecho de que no habiendo llegado aún
el calor intenso a canadá en la
provincia de columbia británica a la
costa oeste canadiense desde hace ya
varias semanas y particularmente el fin
de semana último se están produciendo
incendios forestales lo que viene
ocurriendo en los últimos años que son
cada vez más
duros más peligrosos cada vez más
devastadores y ha habido la evasión de
algunos moradores no muchos es cierto o
12 casas evacuadas en una región sobre
todo en el centro de la provincia de
columbia británica pero lo que me llamó
la atención particularmente fue que ya
con la temperatura todavía moderada que
está reinando en la costa oeste de
canadá el 50 por ciento del territorio
de columbia británica se encuentra en
emergencia se encuentra en peligro de
incendios forestales y hubo una vez más
un llamado de las autoridades a la
precaución por parte de la gente porque
la primer causa de estos incendios es
básicamente la actividad humana
no es solamente el medio ambiente que a
veces también participa a través de
descargas eléctricas cuando hay una
tormenta sino la actividad humana y uno
de los llamados que hacen las
autoridades es que cuando se producen
estos incendios forestales por favor no
interfieran con el trabajo de los
bomberos de qué manera una de las
interferencias que se han registrado en
los últimos tiempos es el uso de drones
gente que quiere capturar imágenes
aéreas de las columnas de humo y del
avance de los fuegos
esos drones ponen en peligro la tarea de
los bomberos y la vida de las cuadrillas
que participan en el combate de esos
incendios así que se agregan no
solamente a esta situación que es cada
año más compleja la actitud poco
precavida de personas que en algunos
casos no hacen más que entorpecer la
tarea de sofocamiento de estos incendios
que lamentablemente una vez más se están
afectando al territorio canadiense
solamente unos segundos leonardo para el
mensaje que tienes así tengo mensajes
media manal condición se ríe saludos y
gracias por lo del vídeo que pusimos
y después tenemos a gustavo luca y se
les mande un vídeo de mi ciudad y no sé
si llegó lo envié el 12 de abril y vamos
a ver dónde vamos a hacerlo pero vamos a
rastrearlo sí y miriam alarcón this
hermoso vídeo el de pablo la próxima vez
que voy a mejorar será el objetivo
miriam pero muchas gracias bueno
muchísimas gracias entonces una vez más
a todos ustedes por participar como cada
semana en este espacio de canal en las
américas el café gracias ángela sierra
nuestra invitada por venir a compartir
con nosotros esta admisión gracias pablo
gracias paloma de las alturas de cortar
semana a semana aquí del otro lado y os
esperamos como siempre la próxima la
próxima entrada en las américas café
chau adiós